when Johnson is here tonight Dave now
you go welcome to so much I am so
excited that you are here I hate to I
really feel like I secret did you hear
you know like the the secret yes yes
that's what you willed it I really just
kept saying it over and over and over
again and it manifested itself here Here
I am oh this is so exciting amazing and
you know I feel like I know some things
about you because you're a master social
media but I feel like there's so much
more that we can learn about each other
so I play this game online a lot in my
videos with friends it's called the
newly friend game so how it works it's
like the newlywed game where we've
answered some very basic place where we
get married I mean let's let's start
slow swing let's start slow fast okay so
we've answered some basic questions
about ourselves and now we have to try
and guess what the other person has
answered in an effort to learn more
about each other and to have a good time
doing it I love it
newly friend game Dwayne Johnson this
feels like a favorite dream never
thought it would happen how exciting
first question is what is your secret
Talent okay I'm gonna try and guess
yours first
all right I think your secret talent is
pillow making mm-hmm pillow
yeah pillow making no I can't do a lot
of things okay but not necessarily that
okay so what's your answer my answer is
I can pick up a grape not using my feet
my hands or my mouth
well it's so wait just using like your
mind well let's have it open in an
Internet you fill in what you think gets
the brake off the ground I'm just gonna
say it happens on a Friday night 1:30
the morning or tequila now you have to
guess my secret talent your secret
talents is oh man smell you may you
smell me yeah I can't guarantee that
you're gonna get what you bargained for
oh I know you secret talent what you
love haiku poetry and you're good at it
oh you got all that from the amount of
dry shampoo that's in my hair right now
uh no I my secret talent is I'm a good
judge of character
Francis watches you're great
Wow awesome yeah next question the
dirtiest words you don't like to say I
feel like the dirtiest word you don't
like to say is taint it's close close
okay it's close okay
what is the answer the answer is poon of
Tang Wow yes bringing the clasp to the
show truly okay the hell of a drink okay
so the word that I don't like to use the
dirtiest word that I hate to say ah Jota
Jota I don't even know what that is but
you know what it counts because C word
whoa Judah starts with the seat that's
what I'm saying yeah so that's
definitely the word is I meant Jota hey
I'm so uncomfortable saying it Jonah
what is the chota it's kind of like kind
of like it like like in the taint area
okay last question I love to send my
best friend pictures of my blank Wow
okay okay you love to send your best
friends pictures of your chota Wow yeah
it's close though I love to send my best
friends pictures of of my blessing
what crew laughing yeah that nickname of
your well it's my cheekbones oh okay
what do you think I send my friends
photos of um your lips my lips um close
I send them my french bulldog obsession
Wow I have one I don't well I love
French bulldogs by the way meet yeah our
family husbands course well this is
Louie he's badass I love when dogs are
named people names oh my gosh okay there
are a lot of rumors about you out there
on the Internet and I asked on my
internet friends to tell me some of the
things that they have heard about you
and I would love to know if they're true
or not true okay so it's dish the dirt
Dwayne right here we go okay
I heard all he has to do is look at a
pistachio and it cracks itself open
that's true is it it's true okay ready
uh-huh
whoa Wow okay I heard that him and
t-swift are besties
oh do you Swizzle t-swizzle yeah of
course I heard that he can break a
window with just a flex of his pecs
it says pecs it's not actually plural I
just flex the Flex of the pack all right
well how dare you Stephanie panousis
produces much a mermaid I knew you were
getting into this dish oh right Wayne
we've learned so much rock you were
gonna sing
and I was trying not to I was really
trying not to but I just felt like I've
gotten to know you so well that I'm
allowed to call you that now